michel drucker michel drucker voulait
tenir une seconde je m'excuse d'un
terrain de voltar t-bonds je leur
présenterai je vais vous demander cage
avec vous exactement 22 ans 22 ans bac
ça pas satisfaire beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui s'interroge sur
votre âge m'a demandé si vous aviez 18
ans 19 ans 20 ans ou fait très très
jeune vous êtes mariés alors je suis
célibataire ça fait plaisir
beaucoup de vos admiratrices ils voient
comment est-ce qu'on devient reporter
sportif à la télévision vont bien il n'y
a pas un système type pour devenir
reporter sportif je parle lorsqu'on aime
le sport et parce qu'on est assez
obstiné et c'est mon cas
en tant que sa chance et puis
pour moi ça a très bien marché bon donc
deux qualités essentielles amour du
sport
ah oui et entêtement meilleur temps
s'est passé pour vous ben ça s'est passé
de façon assez simple avec beaucoup de
chance mais je pensais à ce métier il
faut avoir beaucoup de chance j'aimais
beaucoup le sport j'ai fait mon service
militaire à paris au service
d'information de l'armée où j'ai été
tout de suite plongé dans les milieux du
journalisme en général et j'ai pris
contact avec la presse écrite avec la
presse sportive spécialisée et j'ai été
tout de suite mordu déjà je connaissais
bien le sport et j'ai décidé à la fin de
mon service militaire de 30 et la chance
et j'ai demandé par relation bien sûr un
entretien monsieur marcillac à monsieur
volet qui m'ont pris à l'essai pour un
noir un stage d'information sans aucune
garantie
d'ailleurs moi j'y croyais pas beaucoup
parce que c'était un vieux rêve
difficilement réalisable et puis il ya
les jeux olympiques de tokyo vont
arriver la plupart des records sont
partis au japon
et puis on
besoin de faire appel à moi j'ai fait
quelques essais de voix assez concluant
ce débat merveilleux et enfin c'était
catastrophique
et puis petit à petit je me suis entêté
et faisant partie des meubles
et puis le petit chat quelques jours le
petit des meubles meublants tan dun pas
encore des matches j'en suis regardé mon
ancienne forme à l'amiante une guerre on
avait l'habitude de voir le petit nom au
service des sports comment avez vous été
accueilli par les par les vétérans par
les anciens d'heure je veux dire j'étais
très bien écrit très sympathiques avec
moi plus toute l'équipe était très bien
il m'a encouragé parce que les bus gérés
un facture oui je veux dire d'ailleurs
que le couderc avec samsung le
méridional naturel et léon zitrone avec
tout son poids
on dit beaucoup de bien de tous oui
d'ailleurs je suis très reconnaissant
parce que la première fois ils m'ont
vraiment bien soutenus moralement
puisque j'en ai pas large
calé dans la vie votre sport préféré
notre fait mais c'est le football le
tennis l'athlétisme le tennis durant
votre visage un peu de tennis et wii est
ce que vous avez déjà commenté des
matches de tennis n'ont encore jamais
testé et pour le commentaire alors ça
c'est un cerveau deux bouts de sportif
mais votre goût de jaurès
qu'est ce que vous préférez commenté
commenté avec ma jeune expérience je
veux dire que j'ai
et bien aimé commenter urban gt sport de
balle en général j'aimerais bien
commenté le football parce que c'est
très vivant j'aime bien
j'aime bien commenté aussi les sports où
il faut être assez sobre c'est précis le
patinage
enfin j'aime tous les sports à d'autres
essences dans la vie qu'est ce que vous
aimez under du spa en dehors du sport
j'aime beaucoup cinéma c'est de la
musique mais j'aime surtout la campagne
parce que j'ai envie d'être l entendre
en attendant je suis né à la campagne
par un habitant de mardi je veux dire
que c'est ce qui me manque après si
c'est pour ça que vous venez jouer au
tennis je vais un peu mes représentants
il la télévision va la regarder dans un
train je n'ai plus tellement le pont je
la regardais souvent avant la
journaliste je savais c'est notre cas
malheureux a tous écouté les chiens
michel drucker je vous demande
maintenant d'aller reprendre une partie
je parle un terrain plus longtemps alors
bon sport et à bientôt sur le petit
écran voici